Euh alors je sais pas où on est mais à mon avis, vu le climat.. Euh et la végétation, on est pas loin d'Angoulême ou un truc comme ça...
Hein ?
Non ?
Lol !
Aux Etats-Unis ils aiment bien faire tout en grand.
Mais tout ce qu'ils font c'est toujours grand. C'est toujours plus gros, plus grand. C'est incroyable ! Allô ?
Des grands arbres.
Des grosses voitures.
Des grosses télécommandes.
Des gros panneaux !
Des gros garages.
Des gros numéros de maisons.
Et des baraques pas trop mal aussi !
Ça, c'est mon ticket pour un match de NBA.
Y'a Kobe Bryant qui met des dunks, Gasol qui met des dunks, Zinedine Zidane qui.. met des dunks.
Bon on a perdu. Enfin je dis "on"... Nous les "Los Angelesois".
Alors ici on est où ? On est dans un magasin américain.
Et on va découvrir ensembles toute la culture américaine et les bons produits du terroir.
Allez c'est parti !
Non ce n'est pas du pâté pour chien, c'est du jambon pour les humains.
Les 4 litres de jus d'orange, très typique.
Ou les 4 litres de jus d'o.. De jus d'orange périmé.
Et non, ceci n'est pas un pot de peinture mais de la margarine américaine. Aussi à l'aise sur tartine que dans la poêle,
Et sans acrylique ! *rire*
Tu peux pas être vénère dans un supermarché avec un ballon comme ça.
C'est pas possible.
Ah ! Putain !
Je vais à la maison de Tom Cruise, l'acteur américain.
Et je suis un peu en stress parce que j'ai peur qu'il y est les gardiens et les chiens de traîneaux qui viennent me manger.
Ok, un homme arrive. Caméraman : Un homme arrive ?
Norman : Ouais. Caméraman : Tu penses ?
Caméraman : Tu veux lui demander ? Norman : Donc ce qu'on va faire c'est que... On va partir.
Norman : Oui bonjour ça serait pour rencontrer Tom Cruise.
Norman : Norman.
Norman : Hum... On a des cookies.
Norman : Bon... Ok bah apparemment ça a l'air d'être difficile de rencontrer Tom Cruise... Euh j'ai peut-être une autre solution pour rencontrer des stars.
FUUUSION !
George Lucas !
Haha ! Madonna !
Hop ! Will Smith !
Michael Jackson !
David Guetta !
Michel Blanc !
Comme les stars c'est pas des vraies les gens prennent des photos d'extrêmement près.
Homme : Woh, je suis pas une statue mec !
Norman : Ah pardon.
Wouh ! ici on est au club de patin à roulettes de Los Angeles !
Alors si vous aimez écouter du disco, rire entre amis, et puis également rider un peu sur un parquet parfaitement lisse,
C'est possible, et tout en même temps ! Allez, je vais rider, ouais !
De toute façon moi à la base je suis plus tout ce qui est trottinette...
Cet aprèm' on est allés à Hollywood pour visiter les studios de cinéma. Malheureusement on a pas le droit de filmer, donc on a fait des photos !
Même dans le parking la barrière ressemble à un clap de cinéma, c'est assez énorme.
Bon sur la fontaine j'ai pas pu m'empêcher de faire un 360 flip en skate mais... mais sans skate.
Ca c'est le banc de Tom Hanks dans le film Forrest Gump. Je me suis assis dessus et... ça m'a rien fait de spécial.
Alors on a fait le stage 4, le stage 5... Ca c'est le stage 18, il était vraiment sympa.
Là derrière ce décor il est en train de se filmer une scène de malade d'un gros film américain à gros budget. Mais du coup on est restés derrière. A admirer l'arrière du décor.
On a même vu le château d'eau de cette marque typique qu'on a pas le droit de citer.
Evidemment pour la visite guidée on avait des petites oreillettes plutôt ringardes.
Là c'est le moment de la visite où j'étais carrément content !
Et puis à la fin il y avait même une grande rue avec marqué "Hollywood" au loin. Alors on a pris une photo, et puis on est partis.
C'est très très très beau.
Avis aux amateurs de vues.
Et pour la petite info, Los Angeles c'est 12 fois la taille de Paris. Ca c'est une info à sortir avec une petite saucisse-cocktail en apéro, l'air de rien.
Bon calmez vous les gars, moi aussi je sais faire un ollie, ça va.
Et voilà, c'est ici sur la plage de Venice Beach à L.A. que se termine mon tour du monde, cette fabuleuse aventure.
Salut l'hélico !
Alors merci à tous d'avoir suivi bah les vidéos, c'était pour moi fantastique.
Vraiment, un très beau parcours.
Euh, j'espère qu'on se retrouvera bientôt à Paris.
D'ailleurs il faut que je rentre, d'une manière ou d'une autre.
D'une manière ou d'une autre.